the Holmes takes the snap he's just
gonna throw it long for DeMarcus
Robinson and it's going to use up all
the time the game is over and the Chiefs
Kingdom has firmly planted its flag on
top of football's highest summit ganz
city chiefs are champions of Super Bowl
54
you know we were talking during the
break after we watched that clip that
could have been a touchdown
mahomes throws the ball in bounds and
some in the audience would have been
very interested in those extra six
points that would have made the final
score 37 20 total score 57 on the over
side of the 53 and a half over/under
instead of 31 20 and 51 total points so
that but look that's the ultimate rub it
in play if you're playing somebody in
Madden well yeah I still do but the
Chiefs don't they didn't do it but that
was how the season ended the 100th
season Chris for the National Football
League so let's take some time to
reflect on the full season how will
we've remembered what stands out when we
think of the 2019 season the NFL's 100th
of all time all right well first off all
right like I guess this is to me it's
the year of Lamar Jackson until here
just recently I mean that's where I
would if you would have asked me this
last week I still don't my man sir would
be Lamar Jackson Lamar Jackson Lamar
Jackson but I also think with this
playoff run and this special comeback we
just saw mahomes having the Super Bowl
III think that's gonna overshadow a lot
of that Lamar Jackson magic we saw
during the year because that was some
unreal Kansas City magic in my home's
magic that we saw in the playoffs but I
think those are the two things that jump
out to me more than anything but what
what's say you Floria yeah you know it's
it's funny we had just forgotten about
the Chiefs they lost home games to teams
like the Texans and the Colts Patrick
mahomes was injured he wasn't the same
when he came back and I remember after
that Broncos win in December the
snowglobe game yeah right I talked him
on the phone and and I said do you kind
of like the fact that people have
forgotten about the chief she said I
really like that and we didn't really
wake up until after they beat the Texans
in the divisional round that this was a
team that was a legitimate threat to win
the Super Bowl and even then there were
people who thought the Titans were gonna
win the AFC Championship right because
they would ground-and-pound the Chiefs
and the Chiefs wouldn't be able to slow
them down so yeah it was Lamar Jackson
until it wasn't right and
you know you think back to the full
course of 17 weeks of a regular season
and my god how it all started on August
the 24th well out of the blue on a
Saturday night Andrew Luck retires like
holy crap like how different with the
season have been if he had played right
well I'm that's that's that where I
wanted to go next have a we you and I we
had a full season's worth of you know
talk show crap to talk about before the
season even started Andrew Luck retiring
Antonio Brown Oakland Raiders
cryotherapy AWOL you know all of that
and then let's not forget our favorite
Rogers and LeFleur dumb bum bum bum bum
we had all that leading up to the season
the season even started it was amazing
it really was so you're right Lamar I
mean Andrew Luck's retirements probably
the biggest shock of all that but I mean
those three topics there were huge to
start our football season and we were
all looking at all of them and
dissecting them every which way and yeah
that Andrew Luck thing is still shocking
I almost forget about it now well
because it was quickly superseded yeah
the Antonio Brown fiasco it was just a
week later that you know Antonio Brown
is agitating to get out of Oakland and
and then he's out and then he's in New
England and then he's out in New England
and what we had record traffic in
September all fueled by the comings and
goings in the life and times of Antonio
Brown and and that really hovered over
the entire season and I think that's one
of the reasons why the NFL has taken
their sweet time to investigate a
Antonio Brown they didn't want to come
back he had already been a a distraction
from what should have been a celebratory
season ultimately was and one of the
reasons it was he made one appearance
week to for the Patriots and then we
never saw him again
right yeah I mean it was really well you
know what what we saw from Antonio Brown
this year was it's truly amazing you
know I think we've become a little
become a little numb to it because he's
done so many crazy things over the last
two two-and-a-half years that you know
we don't really put into perspective
sometimes and need like time to digest
it all but I mean come on I mean just
the way he
acted in Oakland of course the feet
being frozen the cryotherapy machine and
then him going off the radar and hard
knocks is going on during that time with
the team he's supposed to be there and
they're trying to act like it's no big
deal even though they haven't seen or
heard from him in a week and they're
trying to pie it off like oh it's no big
deal he'll be ok I mean it was
unbelievable stuff and then you go oh
man he went to the Patriots oh gosh the
Patriots gonna win the Super Bowl that's
it that defense now Brady's got a weapon
and then of course more crap comes out
and he's in deep trouble once again and
he just continued to go AWOL ever since
then and to where yeah now we're sitting
here talking to guys last week at Super
Bowl media row where they're worried
about his well-being and I get it and I
think you and I are in that same boat
where we worry about the man he tried to
launch a Redemption tour with an ESPN
interview with gesina Anderson that came
out Friday Saturday right before the
Superbowl
it wasn't very convincing it wasn't very
compelling he says all the right words
but then he he says things after that
that that continue to suggest he doesn't
get it and that he does need help I mean
he by all appearances and I didn't know
whether or not he had fundamentally
changed since leaving Pittsburgh when
juju smith Schuster told us last week
that this is different than what he'd
experienced kind of behind the curtain
in Pittsburgh that's when I realized
that this cuz somebody needs to get
through to him and all of the he needs
to accept the fact that he needs some
help to get things pointed back in the
right direction or we're never going to
see him again other stories from the
2019 season that stand out the miles
Garrett a course talking Mason Rudolph
in the head with a helmet the most
egregious on-field violation we've ever
seen
Garrett suspended for the rest of the
season for an incident that happened in
November and he's still suspended they
still haven't decided when he's gonna
come back I mean that was a stunner that
dominated conversation for nearly a week
yeah I mean on a nationally televised
game on a Thursday night football where
everybody's watching I mean yes we've
never seen anything like that ever is
that so yeah I mean I wrote the
Cleveland Browns down and all its
disasters I wrote that down and of
course miles Garrett is the biggest
disaster of all in that conversation
but you have Cleveland Browns this will
be a year I always think about about
them as well you know not living up to
hype oh it's Baker Mayfield Jarvis
Landry Odell Beckham jr. man this is
gonna be amazing what can they do on
offense they underwhelmed and then with
the miles Garrett and the Freddie
kitchen stuff and everything to go with
it
yeah the disasters in Cleveland will
certainly ring true to me for 2019
expectations were too high I were pretty
kitchens was so far over his skis he
didn't know that he had skis on and it
just look they weren't horrible but they
weren't nearly as good as we thought
they were going to be and they're gonna
be one of the teams this year that we're
gonna be very skeptical about and it
wouldn't surprise me if they end up
being better than we expect preseason
expectations are so critical to how a
team is perceived did they do better did
they do worse and they did worse last
year and there's a chance at the end of
2020 we're gonna say hey they did better
than we expected
because we don't expect much after what
happened last year
how about Jay right yeah and and and his
status continues to be undecided right
for 2020 right I mean that was that was
amazing and I was at you when we were
watching that game you're like I want
what if this game goes to overtime and
he throws an interception and there it
was last throw of the season
interception pick-six like a microcosm
of the whole year he delivered to become
the first 30-30 quarterback in the
history of the sport and really a
microcosm of his whole career yeah he
threw for 30 touchdown passes and a lot
of them were amazing where you go whoa
this guy is some player but then he
throws 30 interceptions and like 25 of
them you just go man that might be the
dumbest interception I've seen all year
I mean that's what's amazing about
Jameis Winston it's just all over the
place and as good as great as bad is
just horrible yeah and and I do remember
that moment when they were going
overtime I said here it comes pick six
to end the season and to get into 30 and
there it was America's last throw look
he didn't even watch and not that he was
going to catch him but he didn't even
really try to catch who was at Deion
Jones yeah
yeah so it's just what do you do with
him how do you do with though I still
think you have to keep me at 50 109
passing yard I agree highest of all time
I agree he's got a ton of talent you
know you know we've said it we see it I
mean you and I see it when it his great
his good is great it's like top you know
five or six quarterback in football and
you know I would think yes a guy like
Bruce Arians I would think he's got the
confidence that he could fix a few
things about the guy's game to maybe
clean it up but I do think you bring in
a legitimate threat to Jameis Winston
this year whether that's Andy Dalton or
Teddy Bridgewater or whoever somebody
for the sake of Bruce Arians job and the
rest of the organization to wear man
it's week three and Jameis has thrown
two touchdowns and seven interceptions
and we're one and two now we might need
to make a switch to somebody that you
know is a little more consistent and we
can trust so we're all gonna get fired
and lose our job I think that's got to
be the move for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
basically you're suggesting a Ryan
Tannehill trying to supplant Marcus
Mariota eventually but who's gonna
accept that I know if there's an
opportunity to be the starter elsewhere
yeah that'll be the big question you're
right it's gonna be this group of guys
that's gonna go have to feel and kind of
see where the market goes okay how many
chairs are there left for me to maybe be
a starting quarterback okay all those
are filled I can't be a starting
quarterback and then it's gonna be all
right I'm here's what's left over and
what's the best backup spot that makes
sense to where I could go there and play
one and then to also go there and play
and be successful because there's talent
and offense around me and that's where I
think it'll be really an appealing job
for that kind of guy like we're talking
about the quarterback who doesn't have
the the chair when the music stops as
far as a starting quarterback position
is if you use that musical chairs
analogy and I still don't know whether
there's gonna be more seats than butts
or more butts than see ya right right
right
we just don't know there's so many
quarterbacks out there and it may be
that when it's all said and done you've
got some great quarterbacks looking
around saying where do I fit in and it
may be when it's all said and done you
got some teams saying we thought we were
gonna have a quarterback and there's
nobody
left a couple of fun ones on our way out
here first who could forget the black
cat amazing during the Cowboys Giants
game the black cat running around on the
field that I thought was going to show
up again because they never caught the
cat no and the cat is well fed the cat
is eating a lot of leftover food that
makes its way onto the ground at MetLife
hopefully I hope I'd rather eat hotdogs
than mice although I don't know six to
one half dozen hotdogs and mice that's
encouraging I'm glad I worked with the
guy that would rather eat hot dogs and
mice that's hot dogs let me tell you I
had a hot dog at the Super Bowl hey you
were disappointed huh
hard rock Stadium step your game up try
to cook the hotdogs the next time
Atlanta has the best hotdogs and they
are only two dollars which makes them
taste even better
and how about this be careful of the
Gatorade in Washington completely Chris
I know you're a germaphobe just watching
that watching that makes you want to put
on rubber gloves in a hazmat suit
disgusting I mean one you know yeah we
have no idea where that goes guys hands
have been right and now he's grabbing a
plastic sleeve and mixing around the
Gatorade and now he's putting you know
the chemicals of the plastic in there
that is hilarious that I forgot about
that that is one of the great moments of
the year
I mean yeah hey nothing to stir let me
just use the cups and move it around
guys you know it's Gatorade what the
heck it probably can can process all
that all that dirt and filth and foul us
from because think about it where would
the sleeve of cups have been it may been
on the ground for all anybody knows all
right you could add some defensive
linemen who just had his hands down his
jock and then was also blocking somebody
okay and then he comes over the
sidelines and moves the bottom of that
sleeve we just saw move that it's like
oh great that's in the Gator right now
we can all drink some jock sweat and
Gatorade together that's really awesome
you know I think I can always count on
you to take it that one extra step
farther you know it makes us all
petrified that it's going to be our
final show
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports